i think that when you make a social
issue documentary
you ultimately do rely on
grassroots movements to help
champion and disseminate your project
even even though the ghosts in our
machine has been very carefully designed
so that it can move beyond
and help to expand the grassroots
so that it's not just directly going to
the grassroots and becoming a film
for people that already care it's really
designed to reach beyond but
i say that i i refer to the grassroots
with great reverence because
these people that are doing the
difficult work on the ground all over
the world i have huge respect for and
with any issue whether it's
environmental human rights or or animal
rights
and they really help to champion a film
and with the power of social media we've
really established over the last two and
a half years
an online presence and identity and i
think it's through the buzz that's been
generated with these incredible groups
and people individuals all over the
world champion the project that it's
really been
able to
blossom
so when it came time to figure out you
know who in the u.s could we approach to
be partners to support our oscar
qualifying theatrical release
it became
sort of almost an easy ask to go to
these big really savvy
incredibly well coordinated
organizations like mercy for animals and
peta
and
neves and and compassion over killing
and to say look we would love your
support
you know not financial support but we
would love your moral support and your
support through
online social media and marketing
to help us get people to the theater to
help raise awareness to interview us and
and that kind of thing it was not hard
because they had seen the trailers we've
had a website that's been active for so
long they've almost in a way been
watching the unfolding of the ghosts in
our machine in the public eye for you
know the last two years so they were
excited but of course i showed them the
film
with a private password protected link
first
you know they need to see it and see
what am i really supporting here
and
you know they came on board and were
just thrilled to come on board so it's
been a really amazing marriage and i
think that we'll have more and more of
these types of marriages all over the
world um
in 2014
in getting the film out there to
communities and
and having really special events and
screenings
centered around around the film so
it's exciting
you